y
a pas de fumée sans feu à partir du
moment où elle a tenté de voler et
qu'elle dit pardonnez moi je suis là je
suis totalement dj d'allemagne est gelée
pas frappé et quand elle est à terre
gelée pas mis à terre de moi même
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les monstres en live c'est une tare
c'est super de coulon charles avec ma
mère espèce de fils de de gier la d2
mamés et tu vas être muji avis j'ai tout
moggi
alors ce qu'elle a bien fait de diffuser
la wii
moi j'ai fait oui bien sûr daniel way à
moi je trouve évidemment appuyant ac
c'est hyper chaud quand il rentre il est
bête soit disant pour demandé de
l'amener il prend le sakhir pas c'est
traumatisant mais va pas dire est ce que
je peux te prendre un
peu comme aux antilles dhofar ouest
malheureusement non n'est pas dire oui
mais si quand on voit des actions comme
ça je suis dit c'est pas vrai que les
mêmes hamedani encore
je dis pas qu'il faut le protéger je dis
juste que ce qu'elle a fait est illégal
c'est donc tu ne
il a fait des choix déterminants
problème tu ne te ne lutte pas contre
quelques une action illégale on est en
toi même dans l'illégalité
la vidéo tu la donnes aux flics et les
figues bon cherchez pas sur les réseaux
sociaux
excusez moi avec tout le respect que je
vous dois je ne suis pas du tout
d'accord avec vos propos donc j'assume
totalement ce que j'ai fait pour moi
c'est un acte de défense tout d'abord
pourquoi parce que déjà je me fais voler
dans un magasin on rentre on prends mon
sac on se barre je cours après j'arrive
pas est court plus vite que moi alors
que j'ai encore une la moitié de mes
chansons sur la tête
jb oui l'autre moitié l'autre moitié
c'est facile et que j'avais vraiment de
l'effet
c'est pas du super
g staff fait un rappel à la loi alors
moi jouent enfin pas normalement c'est
illégal aussi de voler donc on fait
comment donc je suis la gagne était
alors qui va gagner ce que je vous
propose en fait c'est simplement je
comprends votre peine je comprends votre
chagrin vous avez travaillé cependant je
ne fais pas la loire moi même je fais un
acte de défense et surtout je fais une
enquête par moi même je ne condamne
jamais personne je ne suis pas je ne
suis pas ok c'est pas mal
moi vous êtes enquêtrice mahdaoui votre
mecha tanks et heures n'oublie pas des
gens je publie vous savez qualifier
quelqu'un c'est trois ans de prison
illégale madame c'est illégal c'est
illégal aussi de voler en so lu ment
aujourd'hui des comices à elle et
policiers ont trop de travail pour
s'occuper d'un petit fait comme le mien
ça alors essayez basse excusez moi non
mais la maison est facturé monsieur est
absolument pas ce grâce à cette vidéo et
ben j'ai eu des chemins j'ai eu un
contact avec trois magasins trois
magasins qui ont la même description et
la même vidéo surveillance avec ça
voilà voilà voilà à dire qu'il a fait
oui plusieurs fois et la même semaine et
dans le même quartier du coup est ce
qu'ils aient retrouvé alors ce gars là
n'ont toujours pas non mais bon en tout
cas ils sont sur la piste whaou y mettra
sur la piste
[Musique]
alors table la vidéo a été détenu par
quelqu'un qui a proposé à hicham 30000
euros en lui disant c'est une donne
trente mille euros je ne sors pas la
vidéo et il cham a refusé et il a sorti
la vidéo lui même comme
ailleurs alors déjà moi je pense voilà
non mais je pense que les vidéos elles
sont elles sont sortis puis à dijon
voilà qui ont qui les ont envoyés ici
les envoie vraiment du mois pas
exactement écarts moyens mécaniques y
achever les tuer j'allais faire sortir
qu'est ce qui s'est passé alors s'il dit
pour vous juste une jeune fille qu'ils
ont rencontrés ils ont ils l'ont
rencontré ils sont amusés la suisse d'un
appartement lui est un et un complice
l'on a tiré dans le dressing pour
coucher avec elle ils nous ont proposé
de coucher avec elle me dit en tout cas
sa version et à ce moment là elle refuse
elle refuse de façon comme ils sont
deviennent insistant elle refuse elle
les insultes elles eurent
ils sortent ensemble ça continue à
hurler ce qu'on les voit un moment donné
il savait sa crise et il rentre
effectivement dans cette salle et là
dessus il se met à l'abattre à lui
cracher dessus on entend dans la vidéo
effectivement je la crains que je vais
lui cracher comme toi tu lui a craché
dessus donc il reconnaît qu'il lui a
craché dessus aussi elle a dit je vais
appeler la police et à ce moment là ils
ont tiré à tirer vers le balcon pour lui
dire non non ne fait surtout pas ça
l'est ils ont pris peur non pris
conscience de la gravité des faits et à
ce moment là sur le balcon ils ont
essayé de vraiment de lui dire qu'elle
était attention tu es musulmane tu peux
pas faire ça tu sais très bien que tu as
pas vrai de sortie tu te tais tu abuses
qui a déposé plainte auprès
effectivement de la police tu sais très
bien que toi même tu risques quelque
chose c'est ce qu'elle me dit en tout
cas
le tout de suite puisque l'affairé nom
est celle en sortant de cette affairé
s'est rendu à l'ambassade tout de suite
d'accord pour déposer plainte et ils lui
ont dit à l'ambassade il l'aurait dit à
l'ambassade il n'ya pas effectivement de
preuves vous n'avez pas de vidéo
isabelle rien donc sans preuve c'est
très compliqué effectivement de déposer
plainte il ya maintenant dans un instant
si vous voulez revenir après pour faire
un débrief de 6,9 cm ne pas l'affronter
bien sûr vous alors vous passez par la
première à droite
merci hicham d'être là dire double à je
prends d'être candidat de télé réalité
les princes de l'amour 9 vous êtes voilà
et ce soir mon vous êtes au coeur de
cette polémique vous savez que cette
vidéo elle et sortiront pas du goût mais
savez vous le savez pour voir parce que
j'ai eu des échos j'ai eu des appels on
m'a prévenu que la vidéo allait sortir
après j'ai pas les preuves ou si c'est
réellement vrai qu'il ya du chantage à
part attendre à de l'argent vous parle à
sortir mais j'ai préféré prendre les
devants de diriger la sortir du bois
mais alors qu'est ce qui s'est passé il
s'est passé que cette personne ait
traîné déjà c'était une personne que je
ne connais pas d'accord comment elle
voudrait se retrouve avec vous dans je
ne sais pas elle est arrivé à une
certaine heure elle était avec des gens
l etat est pas qu une copine cité
plusieurs elle est partie faire
plusieurs tours d'ombré si elle arrêtait
pas de fouille et j'ai vu que la touche
à des affaires y avait des affaires un
petit peu à tout le monde elle a
commencé à toucher je veux parler dans
la chambre elle a été assez agressif
avec moi il faut savoir que après elle
m'a giflé faut savoir que si ce qu'on
voit pas c'est qu'elle avait une
bouteille d'alcool dans la main qu'elle
a cassé qu'elle m'a menacée avec donc je
mets au défi quiconque de se faire
menacer comme ça de base par une
personne et de pas forcément réagir pour
tout monde film la proie sa fille c'est
n'importe quoi avec vous
tout le monde rit
je ne connais pas mais il ya une jeune
femme qui à terre visiblement effrayé il
ya une autre jeune femme qui dit arrête
parce que on vous entend vociférer
dans la pièce qui sont en train de rire
amber à ce moment là il y avait un coq
heureusement y'a rien qui match
complètement d'accord avec vous pour le
moment pour le coup je voyais pas ce qui
se passait derrière moi j'étais dans le
feu de l'action ce moment j'étais très
énervée elle m'a frappée après je parle
un parfait je suis pas quelqu'un je sais
que tu vas voir cette faute rôle je fais
pas ma propre police mais il n'y a pas
de fumée sans feu à partir du moment où
elle a tenté de voler et qu'elle dit
pardonnez moi je suis là je suis
totalement
là je vous entends en fait c'est la
seule personne responsable et coupable
ça c'est une fille je peux en train de
dire qu'elle est je suis pas
très grave je juge personne je ne suis
pas
juste vous dire quoi je parle en ma
personne alors je parle en ma personne
je rentre juste que vous dire qu'elle a
fait une tentative de vol et qu'elle m'a
frappé à plusieurs reprises et il ya
énormément de témoin sur place qui
peuvent en témoigner c'est votre soeur
qui est filmé la comment vous réagissez
ben franchement pensé gap c'est clair
que je serai très énervé mais dans tous
les cas j'aurai un disque avec ma soeur
qu'est ce tu fais déjà dans une soie
avec des hommes qu'est-ce qui fait
bourrer dans des trucs et pourquoi il
s'est dans les soirées avec des hommes
avaient
laissé ma soeur ma soeur nous sommes
tous d'accord
l incroyable il ment comme il respire
bien évidemment on le sait très bien
rien que la vidéo ou lundi tiens moi je
vais cracher sur elle comme tu viennes
cracher sur elle des gens ont le sa part
en fait cette vidéo parle d'elle même et
c'est un scoop à vous donner comme ça
que j'aurais bien aimé vous dire à ce
monsieur mais je dirai pas le nom il ya
une autre malheureusement victime qui a
été victime des mêmes faits avec le même
mode opératoire
aujourd'hui entre 28 et 63 ans et elles
disent toutes avoir été confrontés de
près ou de loin aux agissements de celui
qui a été la vedette du jt de tf1
pendant plus de 20 ans je me souviens
juste que j'étais allongé qui m'a enlevé
mon pantalon on ma culotte qu'il est
rentré aujourd'hui elles n'ont plus peur
et elles ont décidé de dire tout ce
qu'elles ont gardé pourrait durant des
années pensons être les seuls il ne nous
fait plus peur parce que nous sommes
désormais ensemble vous a vue sur cette
émission y'a on va passer d'autres
extraits d'avoir complètement fou et je
vous en avais pensé je les ai vus alors
nous déjà à nous tout en a fait un
groupe whatsapp avec les victimes donc
on échange souvent avec elle est la
première chose qui nous a ému c'est
qu'elle formait déjà un bloc extrêmement
solidaire ess qui est très très émouvant
c'est de les voir toute la une vingtaine
qui ont des profils très différents il y
avait des femmes qui étaient très jeunes
et avaient des femmes qui étaient déjà
des femmes d'un âge assez adulte etc et
on voit que malgré diversité de leur
profil de leur caractère de la manière
dont elles ont réagi tout finalement ont
été broyés une la façon de faire de cet
homme et par le contexte c'est à dire
que tout disait mais à l'époque qui nous
aurait entendu qui nous aurait cru qui
aurait pris ça au sérieux tu m'envoies
deuxième extrait on a aussi découvert
témoignage de marie laure e delattre
conseiller en entreprise qui révèle
avoir été violée par ppda le 18 mai 1985
alors qu'elle était âgée de 23 ans je me
suis dit bon comme il m'avait dit qu'on
allait voir impôts je me suis dit je
vais aller boire un pot sur la terrasse
est en fait je me suis retrouvé dans sa
chambre et après je les ai vus tout nu
comme un ver se frotter sur son canapé
qu'est ce que vous faites là moi je ne
suis pas bon pour ça et j'ai pas bougé
je me souviens juste que j'étais allongé
qui m'a enlevé mon pantalon on ma
culotte qu'il est rentré ding dong ding
dong moi j'étais collé comme ça c'est
tout ce qui s'est passé la séduction
excusez moi mais c'est pas ça quand on
écoute le témoignage de ces femmes c'est
une sorte de mode opératoire ppda qui se
dessine nous en fait joffrin jouissait
de son statut de présentateur star du jt
pour leur faire miroiter des
perspectives professionnelles et espérer
avoir des rapports sexuels en échange et
l'autre chose qui est qui est frappant
c'est que ppda ne s'arrêtait pas de
harceler les femmes tant qu'un homme
n'intervenez pas entre lui et la femme
sara keene avait en fait aucun respect
pour les femmes qu'il ya deux femmes qui
ont témoigné qu'ils étaient mineurs au
moment des faits qu'elle décrit donc ça
c'est un une partie très forte elles se
sont réunies dimanche soir l'émission a
été enregistrée lundi puis ils ont
décidé de parler certaines de dos
c'était bouleversant et pour le moment
la justice enquête mais elles sont amers
c'est pour ça qu'elles ont décidé de
parler parce arrière une seule plainte
celle de florence porcel qui ne serait
pas prescrite mais sans qu'elles ont
envie que ça sorte mais rien mais elles
sont aussi amer parce que patrick poivre
d'arvor a les a attaqué en diffamation
sakho pokal cale au mieux et qu'il ya
cette femme qui se retrouve aujourd'hui
avec une plainte alors qu'elles sont
elles estiment qu'elles sont les
victimes et qu'elle trouve que cette
façon d'agir est extrêmement violente
pour elle ou du soutien de ppda vous
êtes romancier roule à vélo nous de nous
avait déjà raconter votre histoire avec
lui que vous avez pensé de tous et tous
ces témoignages moi je ne soutiens pas
j'ai souhaité témoigner de son mode
opératoire par contre je pense que ce
sont des faits qui remontent à une autre
époque il peut pas tomber dans
l'anachronisme
et en plus on parle de 6 ppda j'ai en
fait c'était un système beaucoup plus
vaste un système de société ou en fait
les hommes de pouvoir abuser de leur
pouvoir les femmes jouaient certaines
joué le jeu avec la promotion canapé qui
s'ensuivait c'était beaucoup plus
globale je vois pas pourquoi lui devrait
porter chapeau pour tout un système
patriarcal
voilà je faisais partie c'est les autres
le cautionner ou fermer les yeux et
voilà ça je l ai sandra quand vous avez
entendu là qui disent aimer sur moi il
m'a enlevé le pantalon il m'a pénétré là
c'était pas un système c'est-à-dire des
faits qui doivent être vérifiés
de chocolat
syndrome de stockholm c'est juste une
nuance dans les propos dont j'ai les
idées sont
nulles et un unilatéralisme avec des
positions toujours qui tombe dans
l'excès on peu pas mal gamme et des
actes très déplacé inélégant manque de
respect envers les femmes approche
inappropriée avec un viol par la
violence physique qui est très gras mais
par respect pour les femmes qui se font
violer par la violence physique eh ben
je moi j'ai de la violence physique car
elle mettra gros lourdingue sans violer
dans le cadre même 26 témoignage de il
ya vingt-six témoignages dont sept qui
correspondent à des viols
malheureusement ils sont précis c'est
violent donc qu'ils ne pourront pas
aller en justice mais il ya quand même
26 témoignages qui raconte soit du
harcèlement soit de l'agression sexuelle
soit du viage quelques informations sur
la vie de ppda depuis l éclatement du
scandale il ne sort quasiment plus de
chez lui sa dernière apparition publique
s'était aux funérailles de jean pierre
pernaut où personne ne lui adressait la
parole y compris les personnalités de
tf1 qui la fréquentent fréquenté pendant
des années plus personne ne lui rend
visite à part son frère son fils et sa
nouvelle compagne c'est une femme de 40
ans qui l'a rencontré il ya quelques
mois ça fait quelques mois qu'il avait
ken hill a rencontré dans une soirée
c'est quelqu'un qui est issu d'un milieu
qui n'a rien à voir avec la télévision
et qui selon lui la paix serait beaucoup
et l'aiderait à traverser ce qu'il
considère lui comme une épreuve
[Musique]
anthony et
luna avait 19 ans c'est ça mais
franchement c'est pas ce cas là et voilà
luna l'onas qu'on peut revoir il faut
tenir noda qui était très sympathique
très jolie ou discuter ensemble depuis
combien de temps depuis six mois donc
elle a envoyé le premier ça les premiers
messages sur les réseaux sociaux ouais
donc après on continue à discuter
pendant six mois jusqu'au jour après
l'opportunité nous voilà avec m6 de se
rencontrer dans un endroit magnifique
trophée de ma jeunesse mais tout en me
canalise en proposant quand je lui ai
expliqué moi j'ai des jeunes filles je
veux pas deux enfants à la maison
j'essaie décomptés dans une vie de
famille s'arrête jamais se dit dans
cette es peut-être pas vrai je prête à
m'occuper de sa fille comme je te dis je
suis encore jeune je découvre la vie je
suis allé à mourir au caire juges
préfèrent un repas recherche seul ce
soir
en tout étaient tristes ou pas le soir
j'étais triste parce que toi dans le
sens où il avait l'air sincère en plus
j'aime bien bien sûr après voilà comme
j'ai dis moi j'ai ma vue de famille j'ai
mes projets tout sa nature je tenais
vraiment attaché un ouest après ça s'est
fini dans le sens où elle voulait pas
aller plus loin faut sauver une famille
ensemble assez sur moi c'était le but
aussi c'est quand je te reposer la clé
c'est pas la clé pour rester à l'hôtel
qu'on a un ensemble mais voilà la clé du
bonheur qu'on continue voilà elle est
jeune c'est la clean sortir c'est la
baisse de coûts je trouve que justement
tu as peut-être été un peu angoissant
avec la petite moi c'est ça ouais lequel
tu as trouvé trop sérieux elle t'a
trouvé trois dans l'engagement
directement alors on sait que souvent
c'est les hommes qui fuit l'engagement
mais là je pense que ça a été un peu
gêné depuis six mois et tu juppé est
ressentie je pense un petit peu
oppressés par la situation et le futur
car way a été mature et le causse de
koala dix neuf ans je parle d'enfants de
familles c'est sûr ça peut faire peur
tut tut chez bon une meuf de 19 ans mais
non mais non mais tu chez moi il manque
de 19 ans et était un peu trop mon truc
tu cherchais une belle mère une
belle-mère exil à dix neuf ans lorsque
je pense que là je comprends pas je
comprends lunar aussi ah oui toi mais
peut-être aussi construit mais où il n'y
a ni quand il rencontre et ici elle est
jeune et pourtant il fonde une femme tu
vois la personne mais aussi bien sûr
faire
la part des choses ouaip était lourde
c'est une jeune femme elle a toute la
vie devant elle et c'est vrai que
d'avoir quelqu'un qui lui niveau là je
te veux comme bellemare je comprends que
c'est un que ça dérange il est vrai que
19 ans et 1 c'est une très jeune femme
alors légalement n'y a pas de problème
mais moralement je sais pas si je suis
là c'est que j'ai un peu vieux jeu pour
approcher les gens avant tout je te lis
moi j'avais payé 10 et 6 si tu cherches
est vraiment une fille s'occupe de ta
famille etc c'est vrai que cherchait une
jeune fille de 19 ans s'est peut-être
pas là des castings aussi n'était pas le
bourg lastic briand sauvées ya rien de
choquant c'est juste que l'émission en
raid ils sont obligés de trouver des
angles à chaque fois et que là ils n'ont
pas arrêté de répéter qu'elle a vécu 19
ans et que vous aviez pas ça a été
remonté sur mon pays trafic les sonore
et c'est pour ça qu'il a reçu des
messages mais il ya déjà eu d'autres
candidats qui avait de telles
différences d'âge et personne ne disait
rien c'était personnes et en plus vous
dire anthony c'est un des rares
candidats sincère de l'émission d'argent
les reproches aux candidats d'être fake
des comédiens et vous on sent que vous
est il sincère et le sujet ça dommage
anthony attention ne moment pas d'aller
partout anaïs et tout hanouna ont
débusqué voilà alors bon soir la dame va
arriver valmy en effet battu de walker
texas ranger
la commission d'être jour même où tout
sera nouveau vite en tenir
[Rires]
c'est très bien merci vous a été aussi
et c'est on se rencontrait et oui alors
vous attendez tous le néant
c'était une très belle expérience mais
malheureusement pourquoi vous mettez pas
ensemble c'est vincent rigoler c'était
j'ai 17 ans donc c'est
je
5 août mais pas dit oui parce que c'est
un ami c'est un ami cherrier vous êtes
enfin john était un ami de la personne
que j'étais venu rencontrer non ah ouais
pourquoi les amis le des amis de la
musique
et après non mais c'est vraiment tout
cassandre donc là d'un attendront
c'était ça vous êtes devenu super potes
comme ça ouais c'est bien ça bon bah
super merci
vous êtes amis mais rien n'y a rien
vous vous de vous cherchez une relation
sérieuse alors je vous dire et je
connais très bien droit ne s'est pas
invitée à belle maman
ça va laisser mon
chéri je vais vous donner cinq secrets
de mario premier regard les femmes
peuvent choisir une robe ils ont un
budget entre 1500 et 2500 euros et les
hommes à caution entre 710 euros et 910
au
très beau budget le prix du mariage faut
savoir qu'en france le prix moyen d'un
mariage et de 12000 euros sachez 2 et
celui de mario premier regard c'est
combien ça va lui sont
précis
minimum 13000 euros on avoisinerait même
les 18000 un prix donc ouais ils se
foutent
le prix des alliances la preuve propose
également candidat une sélection
d'alliance ils choisissent ce qu'ils
veulent la fourchette varie 350 à 1225
ce prix de l'or soit plus cher c'est
emile 225 euros c'était un candidat il
ya deux ans 1002 c'est pas mal annoncé
ici les candidats sont payés ouais ça
voici les mariages sont expédiés à
l'antenne en quatre minutes il faut
savoir que sedan vrai c'est très long
une heure trente en moyenne pour que
tous les plans puissent être
enregistrées tout ce temps de tournage
est rémunéré 80 euros par jour il
travaille ses jours étalés sur six mois
et touche donc 1280 euros hormis ce
qu'elle touche en nature un contrat de
mariage et signe comme ça c'est risqué
de se marier avec un ou une inconnu des
candidats signent leur contrat de
mariage le matin du jour de la cérémonie
il pas chez le notaire absents sans se
voir pour signer un contrat de
séparation de biens il dit c'est vrai
oui
alors les mecs or il en faudrait pas
mieux comme ça avec mon zizi mon couteau
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]